Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob. And for the first time in recorded Marvel history,
Wolverine meets Matt, Jim Jaspers. And this is hugely exciting.
I am so excited about this because it's just a cool moment, right?
It's just a cool part of this story. But before we get into that,
we pick up with the next part of our battle, right. Of our X's swords event.
And this picks up and the Holy Republic effect,
which leads to the floating kingdom of Romo Regina kind of passing through a
portal to access another location.
And what we have here is Iliana Rasputin facing off against hogger pod, right?
One of the forces of a Rocco kind of a weird name,
it's a little bit interesting guys, basically like a giant crocodile thing.
But the funny thing about this is that with Iliana Rasputin,
she is prodigious with a sword,
not to mention when you add in the various magical effects that come with the
soul sword, along with her ability to use magic as well.
This fight is a non-starter right, is done.
The problem is this is not a sword fight.
This is an arm wrestling contest Saturday and changes it on a
whim. She's like, Nope, ah, this is a contest of arms. So hands, class,
shoulder square elbows, and the pocket pin to win.
And it's like arm wrestling seriously. And of course, hotter pocket decimates,
Iliana, rest people. Now,
one of the things that we're going to find out here in one of the things you're
going to see over the course of this is that there's something pretty sketchy
going on, right? And we kind of talked about that in a previous video.
Some things pre seem pretty sketchy, but with poker POG, the Victor here,
the score now stands at a Rocco three cacoa one. And so at that point,
we switch over to a place called the blight spoke,
and this is a wholly new environment,
but it was created by Jonathan Hickman in this story.
The funny thing about this is that this is a, an interesting scenario,
an interesting situation, historically speaking,
when it comes to alternate realities and Marvel comics,
every universe that dies is reborn again.
And it really kind of follows the function that that universe is destroyed and
then kind of coalesced into a new universe.
So it doesn't really matter how it happens.
So if you were to take like the main Marvel universe, or you were to say,
this universe reaches his inevitable heat death,
which is to say the point at which it's going to die,
you have the big bang where everything expands outwards,
and you have the big crunch where it all condenses back into a singular singular
point of energy. And it explodes in a big bang and is reborn again. But say,
for example,
somebody like Jean Gray as the dark Phoenix lost her mind and wiped out the
whole universe, the universe would be singularly destroyed.
And that would be the end of it. Right? That would be the end of that universe.
In previous years, it was always assumed that the end of that,
of that universe would lead to it being reborn, right?
It would just somehow come back into existence. Again,
what Jonathan Hickman does is he says, Nope, that doesn't happen.
When a universe is destroyed prematurely. In that form,
it goes to a place called the blight spoke. And the blight spoke is,
is kind of a composite of just dead realities, right?
Where they all just sort of coalesced into a singular landmass, right?
So if you were to say like the United States, for example,
is a combination of dead realities, then like Chicago is like,
there's like an alternate reality. And New York is an alternate reality.
California is an alternate reality, right?
Like all these cities and all these States are all just alternate realities,
but that they all kind of share this,
this sort of energy that's called the blight energy and a sense that when a
person's there, it quite literally drains off your life essence, right?
It'll kill you over time.
That's the reason why Wolverine and the summoner are brought here is because
they are, they have a healing factor and they are,
for the most part indestructable, that's kind of what they're referred to.
But the reason why this fight is so intriguing is because we're Wolverine
finally calls out seminar.
And somebody responds to them that what they end up doing is literally falling
through different realities. And as they fall through these different realities,
they experience a kind of reality shift.
So in one universe they're just covered in bugs, right?
Bugs basically took over this entire universe and killed everything in
existence. And another universe is more old school. And another universe,
you have a scenario where seminar is actually kind of like an old man,
Logan type character. There's one universe where they're all kind of futuristic,
right? There's all kind of bounces.
And it changes around one word like the mini angled, one conquered everything,
right. One where their chess pieces is just any possibility that exists.
There's a universe for it.
And that's one of the things that Marvin never really explored. And in fact,
a lot of you guys had a really cool idea for a video that I will make that I'm
actually going to make on that. Not really a video per se,
but a kind of book series that I'm actually gonna, I'm gonna talk about that.
I'm gonna make a separate video on that because I think it's really,
really cool. But at the end of the day, when it's all said and done, uh,
Wolverine manages to get the upper hand on summoner,
stabs them through the eye and kills him. And he loses.
And the reason why is because Saturday comes along and says, Nope,
this was a fight to the death. Summoner fought to the death, Fanta stay alive.
Therefore you lose.
As you guys can tell odds are basically stacked against Coca-Cola that what it
looks like is happening is Saturday is basically cooking the books in order to
ensure that Precoa loses. Now, from that point,
we switch over to the crooked market. And this is basically just the bar,
this run by Jim Jasper's,
where you have Wolverine and you have storm sharing a drink.
And what we ended up getting is basically a card presented to them whereby it's
a drinking contest, right?
They both have to drink and whoever lasts the longest ends up winning the
benefit of this is that it's a guaranteed victory for Coca-Cola.
It's a guaranteed point.
But the funny thing is that Jim Jasper has kind of have this quick little
conversation with Wolverine,
where he talks about the blindness is bloody magnificent is what he refers to it
as right.
This drink called the blindness is one of the most exquisite things that either
of them will ever put into their mouth. Now, I can't reiterate this enough.
This is the first time this ever happened to me. Let me tell you something, man,
to me, this is exciting. This is hugely exciting.
Jim Jasper's meeting the X-Men for the very first time.
This only matters if you're a fan of Jim Jasper's,
but this guy could end these guys like that. And in fact,
Jim Jasper's will actually show off his powers here in a little while here.
And I think, uh, in the next video that would do who's.
He goes to show off his powers.
You'll see the kind of stuff Jim Jaspers is capable of,
but one of the fan theories,
and this is a genius idea that one of you guys came out with one of the theories
that you guys came up with on discord, as you said,
what if Jim Jaspers is actually the one controlling everything and Saturday,
it's just doing what he tells her to.
He's the one who's actually in control of this.
And Saturday as a servant to him, what if that the case? And I was like,
that's kinda nuts because that's entirely possible, right? I mean, this guy,
a universal shaper, he can control any space that he's in.
It's ridiculous how powerful Jim Jaspers is and a whim.
He could turn these guys into ants, right? Wolverine and storm.
He could break them down and just turn them into stone.
He could turn them into each other.
Why did he get turned Wolverine in a storm and storm into Wolverine? He could,
he could do any number of things, right? This guy, there's no limit,
whatever it is he can imagine doing. It becomes reality, right?
That's just how powerful this guy is.
But what we also into finding out is that as they're drinking this Wolverine
starts to get drunk and that doesn't happen because remember Wolverine's healing
factor keeps them from getting drunk.
Now that is alcohol in the main mobile universe.
This may be an entirely different breed,
or at least that seemed to be the case until we find it,
find out the horseman death. Who's currently a part of the, uh,
of the Iraq enforces working for a while ago.
He presents an artifact to Jim Jaspers and we ended up finding out what death
did is he bribed Jaspers to poison the drink of Wolverine and storm to
make them drunk. Not only that as they start to get drunk,
that the picks up with the next battle between the forces of ProCoach.
So the forces of Rocco that worked at Koa got a battle amongst themselves.
A Rocco got a battle amongst themselves, as well as well.
And the logic behind this according to Saturday,
and is that they all originated from a singular landmass, the landmass of ACARA.
And so in essence, it is basically groups that are part of the same community,
all fighting against each other, right? That's the stance of Saturday and
[inaudible], they're basically fighting themselves. And that's why these,
these kinds of battles among the Cohen and Arakan forces as part of this
tournament is taking place.
But what you end up getting here is basically solemn facing off against the
horseman of war.
And this is a personal vendetta because remember solemn had killed the husband
of horseman work at some point in the past.
But the caveat to this is that if you guys recall solemn and Wolverine met each
other, and a bargain was struck between the two that they were both tasked with
tracking down the Mura Masa blade, and that solemn had gotten his hands on both.
And so he was only going to relinquish his blade to Wolverine if Wolverine would
strike a deal.
And that deal is brought into full freight when Wolverine is teleported away
from the storm and brought to this conflict drunk as a skunk.
And the bargain that was struck was that at some point in time at a time of his
choosing Wolverine would fight in the place of Solomon.
And he's calling in this, these calling in this favor.
Now the funny thing about this is that it doesn't really seem to matter that in
reality here, that because solemn has adamantium skin,
that it wouldn't really make any difference,
war would not be able to defeat the solemn.
So something else seems to be going on here. It is. We don't fully know,
but with Wolverine being here and being absolutely drunk,
he also reveals that he's the one who killed somewhat,
or of course being the son of horseman war. And so solemn killed her husband,
Wolverine killed her son. The horseman war is. And so because of that,
she starts losing it right. Starts going off on Wolverine, full blast. Now,
Wolverine, really, you know, kind of experiences this, this hut.
And one of the things that Saturday Dean really a comment she really kind of
makes here. And what's really interesting is she draws a great,
a great concept here. She says, you've become reckless. You become reckless.
And the face of the fact that one you can heal from anything and two,
the resurrection protocols can always bring you back.
You've become exceedingly cavalier.
You don't know what it's like to fight to the death anymore. And that really,
I would, I would say is a great analysis. That's the winning edge.
The X-Men have lost since they've been on cacoa.
The funny thing is that the idea of creating cocoa or bringing all the X-Men to
that Island in the first place by Xavier was to create a place where the X-Men
and,
and really the mutant population could have their own government can have their
own, their own Island mass, but in the more macro scale, right,
the much larger scale here,
it was all done from what we saw during house and powers of 10,
right house of X powers of 10, uh,
that we basically saw this situation where a war was going to happen at some
point in the future.
And so all of it seemed to have been done for the purpose of making the X-Men
stronger and even apocalypse himself in the early days when his family and his
horsemen ended up inside a Rocco,
he made the promise to his wife that he would make the world stronger.
But in giving people the ability to always come back from the dead,
you make them weaker because suddenly none of the battles that they're in matter
because their philosophy is will no matter what happens, I'll always come back.
So even if it's not a conscious thought, it's a subconscious thought.
Even if I die, I'll come back.
And so they lose the edge that they get when they play for keeps.
And that's the point that Saturday makes that you become reckless.
You become complacent. The Wolverine of yesteryear would have slaughtered war,
right. Would have absolutely ripped through war.
This battle would have been a non-starter.
The horseman war would have died so fast, but over the, over the years,
his healing factor, all those things playing in Wolverines losses edge.
And it's really kind of a way of Jonathan Hickman criticizing the publishing
history of Marvel in saying you've taken away from the full of ferocity of one
of the most ferocious characters and Marvel,
because over time he always just comes back.
And so what we end up finding out is a caveat from having that drink at Jim
Jasper's bar,
as part of the bargain that was struck between Jim Jaspers and the horsemen of
death is that when they were poisoned, it took their powers.
Wolverine has lost his healing factor.
He doesn't have the ability to come back from the dead.
And so you ended up having a war who manages to pin him, get the upper hand,
and then go for the killing blow.
But of course she cannot actually kill him because he has an adamantium
skeleton. But in the end,
the whim is given directly to sportsman war because Wolverine cuts off her hand.
But the problem with Wolverine cutting off her hand is that's not a killing
bloat because Forsman war got the killing blow.
Even though Wolverine didn't actually die. The victory goes to a Rocco.
Now I'm of the mind that has had an IMR playing fair,
the victory would have gone to Wolverine because he can't be killed.
And because he can't be killed, there's no way it can be a fight to the death,
right? So that would have been the end of it. But again,
it's one of these things where it looks like Saturday is intentionally cheating
in order to make sure the forces of a Rocco come out on top. And if that's true,
then the question becomes why. But with that being said, guys,
we're to bring this video to an end,
if you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rod core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and.
[Inaudible].